um well thanks i'm really happy to be
here and excited to share uh the work
that we've been
we spent a lot of time on what we're
going to be sharing today so we're
excited to to have a chance to talk to
you all about it and demonstrate some of
what we've been doing but like rachel
indicated the idea here is going to be
leveraging r and python in tableau using
rstudio connect so this will be kind of
you know the contents of today will
heavily feature our studio connect which
is a paid product but there's also some
open source
offerings that exist based on the work
that we've done and we'll highlight
those as well
um to kind of start off with i want to
i want to say that i think you know when
we look at at art studio and when we
look at the r language itself um and and
python as well i think a lot of
or at least one common theme that i see
is this idea of of being able to use the
right tool for the job right um there's
there's an ever increasing number of our
packages and every increasing number of
python packages that exist to make data
analysis work easier more efficient more
straightforward and things of that
nature um and at our studio we've really
embraced that and and we've extended
that idea of using the right tool for
the job to our professional tooling so
tools like rcdo workbench offer
additional environments beyond just our
studio for for
doing your work in that includes tools
like vs code and jupiter notebooks and
jupiter lab
the reticulate package was created in an
effort to
um make it again
allow flexibility in determining what
what tool is the best tool for the job
that you happen to be working on
just to kind of highlight that this
here's an example of some of the
different you know packages and
frameworks that we see in use today um
on the r and python side and all of
these that we have listed here on the
screen are our packages that have
support inside of of our studio connect
as a publishing platform so
data scientists and analysts and
developers they can build tooling in
shiny or plumber or flask or fast api or
dash or streamlit or tensorflow or any
of these different numbers of content
types share these types of content on
our studio connect and allow business
users to browse investigate explore make
use of whatever it is that's been
developed and shared in that environment
now
we're going to continue this kind of
theme of extending our tooling and our
capabilities by bringing tableau into
this mixture as well right again
following this theme of what what tool
is the right tool for the job and there
are many use cases where tableau makes a
lot of sense when we're looking at
creating dynamic data visualizations
that can be easily shared throughout our
organization and easily accessed from
business users all the way up to
high-level executives
this is something that we've heard a lot
from our customers uh this request for
better tableau integration or just
questions that we receive are you know
how do we how do we use tableau
alongside our studio how does our studio
position itself alongside tableau
questions like that and this is
something that we've i said spent spent
a lot of time thinking about and are
excited to share the work that we've
done here today
now here's kind of where we're going
right um here's an example we'll look at
an example of this same dashboard again
kind of towards the end of our
conversation
today but in this particular example
here that we're looking at we have this
customer analysis that's looking at
customer sales performance and comparing
profit and sales and determining which
customers are performing well which
customers maybe need a little bit of
help
but the really interesting thing about
this particular setup here is the fact
that there are these two different views
here
these two scatter plots that are
based on
extensions that are built in r and
python and then hosted inside of our
studio connect so on one side we have an
r extension that's doing some outlier
detection so you'll notice that these
points here are colored a little bit
differently the blue points are
non-outliers the orange points are
outliers and that outlier detection is
happening in real time um based on an
extension built in r that's being hosted
on our studio connect and we're going to
showcase what that process looks like as
we go through our
conversation today
the other component here is this is this
other extension that's built in python
this extension is built on top of a
machine learning model that will that
takes some set of inputs about a given
customer in their transactional history
and then predicts um their their
expected profit as an output and so on
this left-hand scatter plot what we're
looking at is
actual profit for a given transaction
versus predicted profit and that can
allow us to do things like identify
customers that are over underperforming
and again all this is being driven in
real time by extensions executing r and
python code all hosted on our studio
connect and we're going to look at how
we get there as we as we go through our
the conversation
today so before we go there right let's
step back to the beginning a little bit
and and kind of look at what has led us
to the point where we are today and and
the work that we've done to make these
types of extensions possible
and so to really kind of start at the
beginning there are two existing
mechanisms for integrating python and r
code into a tableau workbook
tabpay is an open source tableau package
excuse me open source python package
that is built and maintained and
developed by tableau themselves and this
basically exists to allow you to execute
arbitrary python code from a tableau
workbook
view the results response back into your
into your
tableau environment our service is a
very similar type of functionality where
you you open up an rserv server on some
in some environment and then you submit
arbitrary code for execution into that
environment and here's an example pulled
from tableau's documentation on how
these types of extensions might be
invoked so we have this script function
here and then we
act in this case this is a an extension
using tab pi so we define our entire
python
process or entire python script here in
this string
we submit that to
our interpreter that's that ingests the
string interprets and executes the code
returns the result and then we pass in
individual values or arrays of values
from our tableau template workbook
now there's a few challenges with this
approach i'm not going to enumerate
everything but but one of them that
immediately becomes apparent is the fact
that if i'm a tableau user like i have
to know at least enough r python to be
able to write my
code into this particular extension or
into the script function um so that
makes it a little bit challenging
because i can't like i have to have some
knowledge of these scripting languages
to really use this or i have to know
somebody that has enough knowledge to
give me some sort of copy and pastable
piece of code that i can then execute
here
um and then
beyond that the the development process
of this code can be a little bit
difficult right there's there's not
really a good way for me to
validate this code there's not really a
good way for me to
debug this code if there are errors i'm
not really working inside of a
development environment rather i'm
working inside of tableau and passing in
some sort of plain text stream that is
then going to be executed as as code on
the back end um a couple of other
challenges that we've heard from
customers of the security with this type
of model can be a little bit difficult
to maintain the appropriate levels of
enterprise security particularly when it
comes to rserve um and so the again
we've heard from customers that these
types of of integrations being able to
execute our code being able to execute
python code in a secure manageable way
from tableau workbooks is something that
that we want
now
moving forward right again starting you
know we started back at the beginning uh
tableau released
this tableau analytics extensions api um
i think it's now been a couple of years
ago and this is really kind of the the
building block for the for all the work
that we're going to highlight today this
this analytics extensions api is
actually the
kind of the foundational piece of the
tab pi integration that they've done
um and so
this
this same framework is what we've used
to provide access to the
to the um extensions that we're going to
highlight today
i'm not going to go into too much detail
here the the goal here today is not to
be a comprehensive deep dive into all
the nitty-gritty components of the
tableau analytics extensions api uh but
rather to give enough information to
understand kind of what's going on and
why we've decided to to go in the
direction that we've gone with the
extensions that we that we're providing
access to
the main thing i think to understand
here is that
this extensions api is really just a
contract that exists between tableau and
some external service right it doesn't
matter what that service is it doesn't
matter what it's implemented in it
doesn't matter what language is it
doesn't matter what it's doing right as
long as it obeys the contract it works
and the contract is that tableau will
make two different requests to two
different endpoints it's going to make a
request to an info endpoint to
understand information about the service
that's running and it's going to make a
request to the evaluate endpoint that is
expected to return some modified version
of the input data right so this evaluate
request is the request that then
returns back um or that submits data
from tableau to the service
the service is expected to respond in a
way that tableau can understand and
reinsert that data back into the
workbook of the tableau environment
there's a lot more detail and
documentation on the tableau analytics
extensions github site that walks
through all the different components
here um but i think it's useful to
understand
just for the context of our conversation
here today that
this external service again can be
whatever it needs to be as long as it
follows the guidelines set forth in this
tableau analytics extension
[Music]
so what do we do when we have you know
some sort of
repeatable behavior that we want to
provide access to end users you know we
again if we want if we want to create an
easy way for users to build extensions
that obey this contract um
what's the best way for us to do that
and the natural
the natural response as in our user and
our developer is to put it in a package
right like let's let's see if we can um
make some sort of a package or create
some sort of reproducible behavior that
will make it easy for people to build
tools that meet this contract that
tableau is expecting us to meet
and so that's exactly what we've done we
have a couple of different packages that
we're going to highlight and introduce
today the first is a package called
plumber tableau
this is an r package
that is built on top of the tableau or
excuse me built on top of the plumber
package so if you've ever used plumber
before
plumber is a our package for building
interactive web apis using r
and this plumber tablet package simply
extends plumber a little bit by adding a
few additional tools that will allow us
to easily make extensions for tableau
i'm going to go ahead and switch over
into a development environment now and
kind of showcase what this looks like
and and how we might go about building
this up and highlight some of the
features of what this package offers and
how it works
okay
so so here's again this is my
development environment we're inside of
our studio workbench here um if i wanted
to create a new we're going to just use
a really simple use case here let's say
that i want to create some sort of a
function that takes some input
some string input and capitalizes it
okay so if i have uh we'll call this
caps let's say this is a function and we
want some string
and then in r this is this is a fairly
straightforward task to do we could just
say we're going to call this to upper
uh string input
right and and really we're just we're
just wrapping this two upper function
here and if we
run this we end up with this caps
function if we say caps
world
we end up with the capitalized version
of that string right
ver again very basic very
straightforward we're not trying to do
anything um terribly complex here
because the focus is less on what we're
doing and more on how we turn this into
an extension
so let's say now that we want to take
this
function that we just created
and turn this into a tableau extension
that we can use from inside of a tablet
workbook we can come in here and we can
say let's first bring in a couple of
packages so we need the plumber package
we also need the plumber tableau package
in here
okay
and then plumber is run if you haven't
seen plumber before some of this might
feel a little bit unfamiliar but but it
hopefully should seem fairly
straightforward uh plumber works off of
special comments that identify different
attributes of the api so here we can say
the api
title
is example tableau extension
all right
okay
and we could say that the
api description is simple
virtualization
extension
okay
so there we have that um and then for
this particular endpoint we need to
define a couple of things one is let's
give it a brief description so
capitalize
input
and then we'll we need to define how
this particular function will be invoked
so we're going to respond to post
requests
at capitalize
so this here again this is all we
haven't done anything unique to tableau
yet this is all just standard plumber
definitions but here we're identifying
that this is going to respond to post
requests at this capitalize uh path
and then there are a few new kind of
special comments that we've introduced
with the plumber tableau package the
first is tableau r and this allows us to
define arguments that we expect tableau
to submit and in this case that tableau
argument is this
string input value that we have here so
here we can say
we're going to call
this school
input
we expect this to be
a character value
and then these are the streams
and then we also have tableau return
we're going to return a character value
and this character value is a capital i
let's call this capitalize
okay
so here's the so far all we've done is
created this endpoint here that allows
us to submit data and return and receive
back the capitalized input and if we run
this right now let's save it so let's
save this as
r okay so if we run this api inside of
our studio we end up with this nice
little
you know user interface over here on the
right hand side we can see our little
capitalized end point here we can come
in and we can try it out and we can say
the string input is hello
world
we can go ahead and execute this and we
should see this output that is
the capitalized version of that input
right everything's good now there's one
critical piece that we're missing in
order for this to be a valid extension
for tableau and that is we need to do
one more thing here and this is this is
highlighted in all the documentation for
the package but we can use this little
plumber annotation
and then we add tableau extension
okay
so this tableau extension function
modifies our existing api so that it
meets the contract that tableau has
established right we we need to be able
to respond to requests in a certain way
and we need to be able to accept certain
types of requests this function here is
what allows this package to handle all
that for you the goal of this package
has been to make it as easy as possible
for our developers to build these
tableau extensions without needing to
worry about how tableau is actually
formatting its
requests and how it's actually expecting
response all we need to do is write our
code and then let the package take care
of the rest and if we run this api again
we'll see that things have changed a
little bit in our user interface we have
some links that have appeared up here
that give us access to additional pieces
of documentation and if we open up our
endpoint here it's actually changed
quite a bit because now
we are
using an example request that matches
the type of request that tableau would
send so tableau sends requests that are
json objects that contain two different
fields or two different values script
and data and here we formatted an
example request that will that will
mimic what tableau will actually send so
in here if we wanted to test this out
again we could come in and add hello
world into our data values
we could try this out let me find my
execute button there we go
try this out and again we see back this
hello world type response okay
now
we have done everything we need to to
build a tableau extension in our and i
want to highlight a couple of things one
it was really a matter of writing an r
function
adding a few comments and loading the
right libraries right the only like
really critical piece here that might be
a little bit unfamiliar is the fact that
we have this requirement that we use
this tableau extension modifier here
that just isn't
again this is an instruction to plumber
to say look
take the existing api that we that we've
already defined and modify it using this
function and this function comes from
this plumber tablet package but once
we've done that we haven't we have a
running capable fully functioning
tableau extension the only challenge now
is that this extension isn't in a place
that tableau can it can reach out to
right this this extension is still
living in my development environment i
need somewhere where this extension can
be hosted
and that's where our studio connect
comes in so if i take this extension
that i just built we can come up here
and we can say let's publish this
to our studio connect
we're going to publish our plumber api
i'm going to call this
example
[Music]
all right we'll go ahead and publish
this is going to deploy this api to our
studio connect because this is really
just a plumber api at its core there's
not anything different or any sort of
unique adjustment that i need to make in
order for this to publish we can see
that it published relatively quickly and
if i come open up our studio connect and
refresh here we should see this
example tableau extension listed here at
the top now if we open this here we'll
notice immediately that things are a
little bit different one we're not
seeing if you've ever published a
plumber api to rstudio connect before uh
you're probably you're likely familiar
with the fact that in most cases what
you see here is the same sort of
interface that we saw inside of our
studio right this this swagger interface
that it's
that we see over here
when we publish tableau extensions to
our studio connect instead of that
swagger interface what we get is we get
this tableau user guide
and the intention here is that this is
now documentation
for the tableau developer so that they
know how to use the extension that we
just published
all this information here is information
that again is specific to the tableau
developer to say here's how
you might use this particular extension
in fact
this extension here can be used by
copying and pasting this line into a
calculated field inside of a tableau
workbook
in fact let's try this right so let me
let's come into tableau
we're going to create a new workbook in
here this will take just a minute so
this is tableau online i'm going to
create this new workbook we
this this extension we created remember
just takes some input text and
capitalizes it so we're not doing
anything really exciting or crazy so it
doesn't really matter the data source
that we select to connect to so i'm just
going to connect to this superstore data
set that tableau comes with
automatically let's save our workbook so
that we can
i'll just call this example extension
go ahead and hit save
then the other thing that we need to do
is we need to set up
what type of analytics extension we want
this workbook to use i'm not going to go
through the entire process of how you
set this up for tableau online we have
detailed instructions
on what needs to happen from the
administrative level to make sure that
our studio connect is set up
appropriately to interact with with
tableau but from my workbook i can come
in here and say manage analytics
extensions connections choose the
connection that i want and then i'm
ready to go
so now i just need to create my
extension the first thing i'm going to
do just to make things a little bit more
interesting for us is i'm going to
create this parameter we'll call this
text input
that we'll expect this to be a string
uh example value will be hello world
okay
and then we'll go ahead and show this
here
okay so over here on the right hand side
now we have this little text input let
me zoom in a little bit
maybe
okay so we have this text input that
shows over here on the right hand side
and now let's create our or let's create
some
part of our workbook that references
this extension so we'll come in we'll
create a calculated field we'll call
this two upper
this can be named whatever and then
let's come back into our studio connect
and we can just grab
this little
script right here
drop it into our workbook let me expand
this a little bit
and then string input is the name of the
parameter in our r function if we
remember correctly but now we need to
make an adjustment because now that
we're in tableau this has some sort of
oops this has a different name now
they're in tableau so we're going to
call this
text
i think is what we called it here we go
go ahead and hit ok
now we have this function to upper let's
drag it into our worksheet
this is now going to submit a request to
our extension being hosted on our studio
connect that request will include this
hello world string and expect that
request to come back as an uppercase
version we see in fact that it did now
it's formatted a little bit funny
because tableau has by default selected
that this value should be mapped to
color we're going to change this to
label
so that we'll get some text output here
in our workbook
and now we see this to upper field
contains the value hello world and if we
adjust this and say something like i
there instead
then we'll see that this field adjusts
to say hi there right
now anything crazy we're just taking
lowercase letters and making them
capitalized but the interesting thing
here is the fact that we have real-time
interaction happening between our
tableau environment and our rstudio
connect workbook now
one thing that i will highlight here
that i think is kind of interesting is
if we come back to our studio connect
we might want to like
because because we have
two different components here right we
have a tableau environment that as the
our developer we may or may not have
control over or be involved in um
we have the tableau environment and then
we also have this extension being hosted
on connect and sometimes it can be
difficult to diagnose if something goes
wrong
what is actually happening right like
how do we how do we debug these types of
extensions
and one of the things that i think is
really kind of interesting and unique to
the plumber tableau package is that it
has some built-in debug logging that we
can actually choose to activate on the
rstudio connect side so if i come in
here i can come into these this
variables
panel here i can set the debug me
environment variable to contain the
value
plumber
go ahead and add this
save
this change what this does is this
inserts this new environment variable
called debug me with the value of
plumber tableau into rstudio connect for
this particular extension and when i do
that and i look at my logs here i end up
with let's go back to our to our little
workbook here
let's send another request let's say
um
good morning
it's morning where i am i know we have
folks from all over the world here so it
might be afternoon it might be evening
it might be the middle of the night but
for me it's morning so we'll say good
morning here
and if i come back into our studio
connect now let's go ahead and refresh
the page
okay so if i look over here on the right
hand side i can see this output
that i that wasn't here before i should
have highlighted that this wasn't here
before but i see this plumber tableau
these all these plumber tableau messages
in the log output
and this is messaging that was enabled
by us setting that environment variable
inside of the environment variables
panel here in our studio connect so now
what we've done is we've increased the
amount of logging that we're getting out
of this extension so that we can
diagnose anything that might be going
wrong and all this information so we get
back information about what types of
requests are being made here we have a
post request being made to evaluate
again
we talked earlier about how tableau
makes makes every request to evaluate
we've done some work in both the r
package and our studio connect to
intercept those requests and reroute
them to the right location i'm not going
to go into all the detail about what's
actually happening behind the scenes but
there's further information about what
is going on if you're curious in the
documentation so we have this this post
request coming in
we can see that the body of the request
is right here it's this json object that
includes good morning as this data value
and then we can see that we're rerouting
this evaluate request to capitalize
because that's what we actually
requested in our extension we can see
that if we look at our let's come back
in here if we look at the definition of
our two upper function inside of tableau
we can see that we request
the capitalize endpoint on this
particular extension right so here's the
extension name or requesting capitalize
that's how our studio connect and the r
package know where to send this request
when it's received and then the argument
that we're passing in again is this text
input here
one other thing that i'll highlight here
and then we're going to go back and look
at some of the other tooling that exists
here is if we come back into our
access settings here we can actually
adjust the url for this this this feels
really clunky right content a bunch of
random numbers and letters and then
capitalize
so if instead we wanted something that
was a little bit more straightforward we
could come in here and we could say i'm
going to call this james pablo webinar
okay
go ahead and save that
once we make this change the
documentation will reload and we see
that our url has adjusted right so now
if we wanted to use this this extension
from tableau we could use this much more
kind of easy to understand script
we could bring that back in
let's just go ahead and make the change
here
i got the whole thing i thought i
grabbed just the path let's fix that
all right
so now we have a much kind of easier to
read path to our extension here
everything else remains the same we can
go ahead and apply this and we'll see
that the behavior remains consistent
with what we saw before we're submitting
requests here let's just verify
it again and we see hello world return
back over here
okay excellent so let's come back to our
slides now that's plumber tableau right
now i mentioned there were two open
source components to this one is what we
just looked at which is plumber tableau
the other is this new component this new
python package that we've created called
fast api tableau
now as the name would suggest this is a
python package built as an extension to
the fast api python package that allows
us to do the same exact thing that we've
just done in
r
but using python right we can build
these tableau extensions using python
using a python framework that we're
comfortable familiar with
and we can submit those and we can
publish those extensions to our studio
connect i'm not going to walk through
that whole process again on the python
side just because it very closely
mirrors and mimics what we did on the r
side but i will pull open an example
for us to look at so let me
just showcase what this would look like
here
so here is and and all these examples
that we that we walk through are are
available in a github repository i'll
share the link to that at the end of the
talk here so you'll have access to all
the example code that we've that we've
explored let me find what i'm looking
for
there we go okay so if we look at
this
all right
so here is a python script that does the
exact same thing that we did on the r
side takes some input text capitalizes
it and returns the result again not
anything exciting in terms of
functionality but this does highlight
how we would use this fast api tableau
package to build these kinds of
extensions and what's really kind of
cool about this
is the fact that the only real
difference between a tableau extension
built using fast api tableau and a
regular fast api router is that we
import fast api tableau instead of fast
api and we instantiate our app with fast
api tableau instead of fast api
these two changes
are the only things that change between
a traditional fast api router and one
that can function as a tableau analytics
extension and again if you're curious
kind of about the technical details and
implementation of the package and and
what the package is actually doing
behind the scenes uh the github
documentation walks through some of that
and can highlight uh the components
there but this this extension here this
this python script again does the same
thing if we look at this on
our studio connect we've already
published a version of this so let me
pull that open here
let's come back to just content ion okay
so we have here's our capitalize
endpoint that we've created in python
you'll notice when this pulls open that
this
documentation and interface looks
different from what we saw on the r side
uh the goal is that those two
differences those those two packages
polymer tableau and fast api tableau are
going to converge as we continue to kind
of iterate on them uh
just as it so happens that the way that
we went through our development cycle
uh the our package was developed first
the python package was developed second
we introduced some new things into the
python package that we're now working on
porting back into the r package and and
those changes will be made in the near
future so one of those changes is this
is this difference in the ui that we're
seeing here but we have the same
functionality right we can click on this
link here using tablet workbooks we can
see the same kind of documentation that
we saw previously on the r side
and then we can also do things like view
the traditional swagger documentation if
we wanted to do things like troubleshoot
requests on our studio connect and
investigate if those requests can can be
served
okay so we've already kind of you know
we've talked through this but let's just
highlight it once again right tableau
the tableau analytics extensions api
is basically just a way that tableau
sends requests to some service and
expects a response back and what we've
done with plumber tableau and fast api
tableau and some product changes that we
made in our studio connect is we've
allowed this other service
to be our studio connect i can publish
fast api tableau
extensions i can publish plumber tableau
extensions onto rstudio connect and i
can use those extensions from within my
my tableau workbooks
and we've looked at what an example of
this looks like on the r studio connect
site right i have documentation
available to me i can i can interact
with my api i can see exactly how a
tableau user should leverage that api um
leverage that extension i can view
documentation i can turn on debugging
there's lots of things that i can do
once this has been published r studio
connect that allows me to
to continue to both serve my my end
users my tableau developers as well as
do any additional debugging or any
additional work that i need to do on the
on the development side
so here's what here's a kind of a more
comprehensive example we'll take a look
at this dashboard here in just a moment
but but here's an example where and this
goes back to the
the tableau workbook that we looked at
kind of at the very beginning where we
are submitting information about a given
customer in their transactions to a
machine learning model that was built in
python were generating predictions based
on that input data submitting those
predictions back to tableau and then
visualizing them in that template
environment and here we see again the
same pattern we use this script function
in our calculated fields and then we
define the path to the endpoint that we
want to or the path to the extension
that we want to use and then the values
from our
workbook that we want to pass into that
extension
[Music]
so let's contrast for a moment the two
different approaches right we talked
about how in the beginning
we have tab pi we have rserve as
existing integration points for
executing r and python code within
tableau
the pattern for those extensions
is what we're seeing here right i have
some script function and then the first
argument to that script function is the
full script that i want executed in this
case it's the entire python script that
allows me to do this clustering of of
data points
just to reiterate some of the challenges
of this particular approach it requires
that as the tableau user i have the
ability
to or i have the understanding and the
knowledge to write the script or i have
the ability to rely on somebody else
that can write the script and then i can
copy and paste it in i don't really have
a great way of debugging this right i
can submit this script if it errors out
tableau will tell me that an error
occurred but it doesn't give me a lot of
additional information about where that
error happened or what the cause of the
error was and it becomes a very kind of
repetitive trial and error process to
get something like this working
i also don't have any sort of syntax
highlighting or any other developer help
when it comes to writing and creating
the script inside of tableau
the last thing this is just this is my
own kind of you know again personal
perspective on this is it's also a
little bit
nerve-wracking to me that this is just
arbitrary code execution in some sort of
remote environment i don't know what i'm
i could put anything in this string and
my remote server is going to try to
execute that um hopefully i'm not
putting anything malicious here but if i
am it's still going to try to execute it
on the back end
this new approach that we're suggesting
and that we've highlighted today is that
instead of submitting arbitrary code for
execution we instead
provide a path
to a predefined extension that we would
like to execute
in this case that extension if we were
going to take this same example where
we're doing this cluster analysis of of
spatial data points
we could
create that extension using something
like fast api tableau we could host that
extension on in an environment like our
studio connect and then we could simply
refer to that as by it by name we're
reaching out to
this location in our extension
environment which is our studio connect
and we're passing these values in
and hopefully we're able to kind of see
the difference in these two approaches
right here even if i don't have any
understanding of python or r or fast api
or plumber or any of these tools
i can still use this extension
if i'm really great at tableau
but i never spend time in r
i can still make use of what my r
developer has done if i want or python
developer is done whatever the case is
because all i need to know is what the
name of the extension is and then what
values i wanna i need to pass into it
so what are some of the the advantages
of this particular
um
of this particular approach well we've
talked about some of them but just to
kind of revisit a few one is this is the
only
solution that exists today where you
could use both r and python extensions
from the same exact tableau workbook
right um
the other other solutions the existing
solutions today like rserve and tabai
work um we've seen customers use the
utilize those um but
you you have to choose one or the other
you can't support rserve and tab pi
execution from the same workbook or from
the same tableau and tableau
worksheet
it has to be one or the other with the
extensions that are hosted on our studio
connect because you can host r and
python extensions in the same location
you can use r and python extensions
alongside one another inside the same
tablet workbook
you also have the advantage of the
enterprise level security that our
studio connect provides access control
you have a very all processes on rstudio
connector sandbox
you're not allowing arbitrary code
execution but rather you have a
predefined
functionality within an extension
that extension gets invoked when when
it's called from tableau but tableau
users don't have the ability to pass
arbitrary code into our studio connect
and then all of these extensions are
behind the authentication layer that our
studio connect implements so when we set
up rstudio connect to refer to these
extensions we do so by supplying an api
key that is then used whenever these
extensions are invoked
this third point is one that i think is
is most significant and that's the fact
that r and python developers can be
separate from your tabular developers
right we could have a team of
statisticians and data scientists that
are building these kinds of extensions
and and providing them on our studio
connect and those developers can be
entirely separate from
the the business analysts that are using
tableau or they're the tableau
developers that are building the
workbooks i don't have to be an expert
in both sides right personally i i find
myself doing a lot of r in python
development i don't spend a lot of time
in tableau right i
i'm not i don't consider myself a great
tableau developer even now after
spending a lot of time in the product as
we've worked through this this process
but what that means is i can use what
works for me right i can use the tool
that's right for me and i can build
machine learning models i can build
business logic i can build whatever i
want to using r in python
and then i can easily make that
functionality available to my tableau
developers who might not spend a lot of
time in are in python but they're really
really good at tableau right this is the
idea that we started with at the
beginning let's use the right tool for
the job
and this is all about enabling that that
choice even further
the last point that i'll mention here is
environment management provided by our
studio connect so
one of the challenges that exists today
with tools like our server and tab pi is
how do we make sure that the right
packages the right modules the right
environments are in place so that when
we submit code to be executed it
executes in the manner we expect right
if i try to
load the tidy verse but my rserv
environment doesn't have the tidy verse
then i've got to go through some process
to contact the admin of that environment
have them make the tidy verse available
then try publishing or then try
executing my code again
our studio connect is different in the
sense that any time we publish any
extension whether it's built in python
or r
the environment is automatically
recreated and managed for us on the r
studio connect side all that happens
automatically i can have different
versions of different packages used by
different extensions and it's all being
managed by our studio connect
the other thing that i that i didn't
highlight here but i think is worth
calling out is that we also have the
scalability introduced by studio connect
so if if i have an extension that's used
in lots of workbooks and there's lots of
users on those workbooks all the time
and so that extension gets lots of
traffic our studio connect can spin up
new processes to support the load
against that track i guess
some resources and again we'll
distribute slides and everything like
that so that you can have the links here
but there's a blog post that we put out
uh a couple weeks ago that highlights
the our studio connect release and the
tableau integration that it includes uh
and then here there are links here to
the plumber tableau github repository
the fast api tableau get a repository um
this collection of examples here at the
bottom is a repository of of
tableau examples that we're building out
it includes the capitalize example that
we talked about today as well as the
other workbook that we briefly looked at
and then one thing that i that i didn't
get a chance to really work in here
today but i will leave here as a
reference and um and you can kind of go
check it out is the shiny tableau
package this is kind of a package still
in in somewhat of a of a beta release
but it allows you to create a different
type of extension for tableau where you
can embed shiny visualizations within
your tablet workbook so the the
extensions we focus on today support
real-time execution
from r and python back into tableau
shiny tableau is focused on a different
problem and that is
embedding additional visualizations into
a tablet workbook supported by shiny and
the link here will take you to the
documentation for that package
finally if you you know
want to take a look at the resources
that we've walked through today or
revisit the slides or anything like that
this link will take you to a github
repository that um
that includes all the the information
that we've gone through today so it
includes the slides and then the slides
have links out to the additional
resources that we've discussed so feel
free to jot that down and and go visit
that and take a look i will in fact i'm
going to drop it in the chat here just
so that you have
just put it there
there's a lot of great questions on
slido too james
yes i will pull that up and take a look
i could say um i can read things i can
read
that would be them
i'll read them out to you and and thank
you kelly o'brien from the rcd team was
helping to answer
some of those questions as they came in
as well
but one that had actually the most
upvotes was are there any plans to allow
integration between our studio connect
and power bi
yeah no that's a great question so
so that's it's a question i've asked
myself a lot of times too um
i can't speak to anything concrete right
now it is something that i plan on
looking at because i i want to know the
answer to that um but i haven't
investigated it enough to have any sort
of definitive answer other than it is
something that i plan on looking at um
that's that's the most i can say about
it right now but i would i would love to
see that happen right i would love to
see a similar style
uh kind of integration happen on that
side of things but it's not anything
that we've made any real progress on at
this point but it is like i said it's on
my it's on my radar for the very near
future to at least start exploring that
idea
awesome thank you james and also just a
a quick note because i know this was
also a popular question um it the
recording will be shared to everyone um
we show the meetup recordings up to the
rstudio youtube as well
and so i'll include that link that james
shared on the youtube recording too
uh the next
most upvoted question james is what are
the limits on what kind of data i can
pass from tableau to r for example can i
pass something more complicated than a
single single string
yeah yeah great great question let me
see so this was behaving a little bit
slowly earlier but let me see if this is
working now yeah so here's here's an
example we didn't we didn't get to this
because i wasn't sure if it was going to
behave but it looks like it's decided
that it's going to behave now um so this
is this is uh kind of what we were
looking at a little bit earlier uh with
a screenshot where we have
uh this
kind of superstore data set here that
contains a bunch of transactional data
for customers and we're
trying to identify customers that are
outliers and so what we have is we have
this extension hosted on our studio
connect in r that does some outlier
detection given some input data
and in this case what we're sending i
think
i don't think i have logging enabled on
that extension actually but but we're
actually sending i think it's like 19
000 records of data
from
from
tableau over to the extension and then
the extensions computing across that
data and then coming back into into
tableau so you can do you can do much
more than just a simple string um
apologies if if we kind of got a little
bit sidetracked with the simplicity of
the original example but but you can
pass any number of things so let me let
me actually pull open this other one too
here if it'll
if it'll open up for me um so
the other example that we have in this
particular workbook and this in this
workbook and all of its extensions are
included in the example repository that
i link out to from the slides so you can
go kind of poke around and see what's
how these extensions are implemented and
everything like that but
um
this this other example that i'm pulling
up right now
is a python extension that has a really
really simple machine learning model
behind the scenes that takes a bunch of
input data let's look at the let's look
at the um
definition
here there we go so we're we're passing
over all of this information from
tableau the days to ship actual days to
ship scheduled quantity sales discount
and then all of this gets passed as
individual arrays over into
our extension uh the way that both
python and our
the the respective python art packages
have been implemented there's a lot of
kind of cool stuff that we do behind the
scenes to make it really easy to like
ingest these types of requests um so
they're automatically parsed and ready
for use inside the body of your of your
functions um but the idea is on the
python side in fact i'll just pull this
open because i've got it right here
on the python side of things if we look
at this
i'm not going to go through this whole
script because i don't think it's with
it it doesn't make sense in the scope of
the
the webinar right now but if we look at
the actual
definition of the endpoint we're just
defining
the values that we're expecting from
tableau
building those into this list and then
running them through this model pipeline
that does a little bit of feature
engineering runs the data through a
model and generates a prediction
and on the tableau side when we look at
this
we're getting this oops where did it go
here we go on the table side when we
take a look what we're getting is we
have profit which comes from our
original data set on the x-axis and then
we have predicted profit which is the
output of our extension on the y-axis
and this allows us to you know identify
okay who's who's over-performing based
on what we would expect them to do who's
underperforming things like that but
this the to go back to the original
question this example is much more
involved than just a single string we've
got multiple numeric values arrays of
values that we're submitting to the
extension
and then generating a result and
bringing it back into into tableau the
one thing that i will note is that you
can only return a single array of values
back to tableau you can't return like a
large data set containing multiple like
multiple columns and things tableau will
only accept back a single array of
length equal to the length of the data
submitted
thanks james
vanessa asked a question can a
visualization hosted on tableau public
leverage extensions hosted privately on
rstudio connect
great question it it cannot tableau
public doesn't support analytics
extensions um for a variety of reasons
tableau online does um but but obviously
that's different from from tableau
public so you you can't do this on the
on tableau public unfortunately
thank you um and then also is there a
way to host shiny apps through tableau
server
there's there's not so we didn't we
didn't spend time just i wanted to kind
of keep things a little simple but we
didn't spend time with shiny tableau but
i did want to highlight it and let me
bring it up here so shiny tableau to be
clear does not allow you to host shiny
applications on tableau server but what
it does allow you to do please give them
a little bit as this kind of screenshot
suggests is you can embed shiny
applications that are hosted on our
studio connect into your tableau
environment so our studio connect is
still hosting the actual application and
visualization but it's being embedded
into your tableau environment and it's
more than just like a static embedding
it's actually it's actually a really
interesting package um it might be worth
like another meetup or another
discussion that's something we'll
discuss internally but what shiny
tableau allows you to do is build these
extensions these visualization
extensions that are hosted on connect
then embed it inside tableau and they
they're responsive to changes in your
workbook so if you have filters that get
applied to your workbook the the shiny
embedded visualization will change to
reflect the the new values
based on those filters and things
thanks james
there's quite a few questions if it's
okay if we go over a few minutes
yeah i well
i would say yes but my daughter is
performing her halloween program at 11
so i'm going to jump off and go and go
catch her for that but
but yeah go ahead
i'll try to get as many questions and i
know kelly is on as well who may be able
to to help too
but john asks can we use this as a way
to clean data as part of the data
refreshing
yeah so so there's i know tableau has
like their tableau prep process that
that is kind of like that
initial
data load data refresh process i i
haven't spent a lot of time again it's
on my short list of things to look at
about like
what role r can play there these
extensions i don't see playing a role
there uh at least as things currently
stand right these are meant to be once
we have our data inside of our workbook
and we're using that data
how do we how do we get real-time
interactivity with with r and python
that's the focus of these extensions i
do think that there's a space for r and
i do think there's even existing
functionality with tools like r and
python in tableau prep um but i'm not
like i said i just i haven't spent
enough time there to know kind of what
the existing landscape looks like as
well as any you know any things that we
might try to bring to that landscape as
well but it is is on my short list and
something that i plan to look at
thanks jane um so let's see we have time
for two more questions because i want
you to be able to
run right before the top of the hour um
one was from jackson
would you need to create separate
security permissions for our studio
connect extension versus dashboards
built in tableau
yeah so i'm not sure if this question is
about the security that we need to
provide on the tableau side or on the r
studio connect side um on the so i'll
speak i'm more familiar with connect so
i'll just assume that we're going in
that direction but on the connection
feel free to jump into i can
allow it so you can unmute yourself
too yeah yeah it's really around um
the
the security to call the api and then if
it's i guess around embedding that
permission on the tableau dashboard so
that
i guess like do we need
a
number of users need to also have
uh permissions in rcu connect and also a
tableau uh you know license
yeah yeah good good question so tableau
users are gonna need to have a license
to like view the dashboards um but
you're not gonna need a license like
like a tableau license isn't necessarily
invoked when you're calling these
extensions if that makes sense so on the
on the tableau side when you set up
these extensions the way you do that is
from the admin side of either tableau
server or tableau online you can also do
this on tableau desktop as well but i'm
focusing on serving online here you can
come in and create new extension
yeah new connection and then here you
put in you know this is the rstudio
connect or whatever you want to call it
you give it the hostname and port of
your rcdo connect server and then this
username and this is all in the
documentation but this username is
rstudioconnect and then this password is
a connect user api key
and the important thing to understand is
that this api key is the key that will
be used for every extension that you're
accessing on this host so what our
recommended approach is is to create
some sort of like
quote unquote service account user on
your connect environment that's called
tableau or tableau extensions or
extension user or something that effect
and so you would come in here
after you create that user you generate
a key for that user and use that key
here and then on the connect side for
any extension you wanted to make
available you would just add and we
haven't set this up on our environment
yet but we're in the process of it you
come in here and add like that tableau
user or tableau extension user or
something like that
thanks james i don't want you to miss
the show
so we
we'll let you run and thank you so much
for awesome presentation but we have
kelly o'brien on still um from the r
studio team and kelly was helping to
answer the questions on slido 2.
so i can ask some of the questions to
kelly
well thank you
appreciate the time today
thanks james
um and also want to let people know as
we approach the top of the hour if other
people have to drop
though we do have another event next
week with tom mock from our studio team
who's actually going to be walking
through
an rstudio hosted evaluation
and so that includes our studio connect
which you saw today which i know many
people on the call probably already have
but if you don't i'll just put that in
the
chat as well
and if anyone else has other questions
too or
something that wasn't covered today you
can always feel free to
reach out to me directly
i'll just put my email in the chat too
and i can always help connect you with
someone from the r studio team
but thank you so much kelly for jumping
in here
one of the um
let me just go through a few of the
other questions
one that someone had asked is if we had
paid for our studio connect what is the
incremental cost of adding tableau
and i saw you had answered that there
oh i need to unmute you kelly sorry
there you go
okay cool
yeah so i answered that one in the chat
um we are not currently resellers of
tableau today in any capacity um that
that might be something we explore as we
do a partnership with them
potentially but today we have no
official relationship with tableau so
you have to
go through them to figure that out
unfortunately so i don't have any
information there
thanks kelly brody had asked could
something like plotley or hide chatter
be put into tableau via these apis
yeah so for that one i would explore
um probably iframing that application
that's been hosted somewhere else
or potentially that shiny tableau
package that
james previewed a little bit
a shiny tableau is a little bit
different than iframing because it
involves actually
building out a dashboard extension
and that's a little bit more complex but
the
documentation site for shiny tableau has
a little bit of a video that that joe
chang put together of
a demo of what that looked like so if
you're interested in learning more about
shiny tableau
i would start with the documentation
site and watching that preview video
thanks kelly
um i see that prabha asked are there any
enterprises known to the rstudio team
that have connected our studio connect
to an enterprise-wide tableau deployment
i know it might be a bit early for using
this
particularly but do you know kelly
yeah i don't think we have any examples
of customers who have
set all of that up and are willing to
talk about their implementation at this
point but
we can definitely
start thinking about that with our
product marketing team and i'm sure that
rachel would love to have somebody if
anybody on this call is interested in
setting something up once you are in a
good place to share what you've done
coming back to this group and and
talking about the experience would be
excellent
i'm just going to say that kelly anybody
if anybody is going to start playing
around with this right away i would love
to
welcome you back to the meetup
um one other question is is there a way
to somehow reverse engineer the tableau
dashboards to our code
they said these tools seem geared
towards r to tableau
we already have the tableau process in
place though
they are for sure geared towards
r2 tableau and not the other way around
we are
opinionated in that respect
trying to help out
the our users specifically and and
python users as well so we have a
companion package called
fast api tableau also for python
um
but
i would be
quite interested if if there was anyone
in the community who was playing around
with methods of taking tableau
dashboards and and making
turning them into
shiny or generalized our visualizations
or code that would be very cool
i'll also say if anybody would like to
chat more about this too or schedule
like a virtual coffee or something
um and i'll invite you as well kelly
feel free to just email me if if you're
interested and i'll just put my email
again in there
um a few more questions uh do you have
to host extensions on our studio connect
or are there other options for hosting
you don't the packagers
are
like generalized and open source and
meant to be
you know like
uh work really well with our studio
connect
but that's not a requirement the things
that are nice that you get with our
studio connect is
management of
those api keys so
your authorization and authentication
needs and the automatic handling of
requests
to that evaluate endpoint that get
rerouted to the actual extensions that
you want to be sending
your quest to so that gets handled on
the connect side for you if you were to
host
these
outside of connect you would have to
write that logic out yourself
thank you kelly
um another question that had a few uh
votes too was from vanessa
and vanessa asked could you speak some
to why
if an organization has our tooling and
staff capabilities
they wouldn't just build visualizations
and shiny
um i replied to this one too i said we
would love it for more people to just
build uh
visualizations and shiny um
but we know that that lots of
organizations have already made big
investments in tableau and so you want
to be
you know
good citizens of the analytic
infrastructure marketplace in space and
recognize that there have been those big
investments and and show how the r
studio tooling and the r and open source
are in python
packages can play well in that space
so
long
answer to just say yeah we would love
for more people to just feel shiny
thanks kelly and if other people have
ideas too or things you'd like to share
feel free to use the chat too i see
a few people were commenting in there as
well um and another question kelly is
still new to all this but if we're
working with sparkly r
can we push to tableau through that as
well
that's a really good question i think
that like there's nothing
preventing that from being a pattern
that
you explore um
the things that you want to be kind of
cognizant of when you're interacting
with a sparkly r as you probably are
aware is that you want to
be sure that your code is not pulling
down more data than you need at any
given time
so
that's always a concern when you're
working with big data and you're trying
to pull things down into visualizations
um
and
and i think that james and edgar are
really great people to start building
out some examples of what that might
look like
on the r studio side so i would
definitely reach out on the community
page about that specifically if you have
any any
tactical questions around how to get
started
awesome
is there a limit to how many analytics
extensions can be used
on tableau's server site would this work
for only one extension
yes so tableau server sites have
recently lifted
the
restriction around a single extension
and i think when i answered this i
interpreted it from like the
the uh
the connect perspective on the connect
side you can publish as many of these
plumber tableau and fast api tableau
extensions as you want
and they get routed from requests coming
through the evaluate endpoint once
you've set them up to work with tableau
so
there's sort of an unlimited set on the
connect side and
i believe the restrictions from the
tableau side for the number of
extensions you can register has also
been lifted for site that
definitely check on the tableau or i
defer to the tableau documentation on
that
great thank you
i saw you also shared documentation for
this question in the chat which was does
this work with tableau's server also
yes and we have integration docs on our
docs.or studio.com site so
it works with tableau server tableau
online and tableau desktop
essentially should work anywhere tableau
allows tableau analytic extensions to
function
those are the three places we know of
thank you
um i
i'm not sure if this question was
answered in another way
earlier by james but um jay asked can
you elaborate on how authentication
works between tableau and connect
yeah hopefully
what james demoed right before he hopped
off was an answer for that but yeah like
at a high level you have to set up an
api key
hopefully
that represents you know a service
account user on the connect side
um and then you register that as an
admin on the tableau site and the
instructions for doing all that are at
that same docs page that i just uh that
we just linked
great thank you and kelly let me know if
you have to run to a meeting i'm just
firing these questions
i probably have to hop off in a couple
of minutes yeah okay we'll take two more
then
um
there was an anonymous question that
said with rserve i've been unable to
publish tableau dashboards that were
using r in a server that hosted tableau
dashboards does the plumber package
address that
yeah if you can
use tableau analytic extensions and serv
plumber tableau or fast api tableau
either on our studio connect or
somewhere else then this should be a
replacement for our serve
thank you kelly and we'll take
one more we'll say two more questions
here
derek asks what are the limitations of
the api from a data perspective
how much data can be passed in return
and what are the data type restrictions
so i think james would be much better
suited to answer this one um
there are a couple of different script
definitions from the tableau side that
you have so you have like
uh some restrictions there um most of
the restrictions are
are on the tableau side
um
and
and from
the api perspective
um
we've we've added a bunch of
tools for you to turn on
um
debug logging at various different
levels so that you can see
the latency and what actual data is
being passed through the request
and that should be
hopefully really helpful to you when
you're trying to figure out
whether you've overdone it it's
something too much and um
the
the actual
the ability of tableau to process the
data you're sending over from connect is
going to fall over
uh we're only able to expose like what's
happening from connect's perspective
though like tableau in many respects is
kind of a black box when it comes to
understanding what its limitations are
um
so
i i would encourage you if you have if
you run into those
restrictions to uh to reach out to the
folks at tableau and make it known that
like you would love to see more
transparency
around
what it what its capacity is
awesome
one last question i said just came in
was
we mentioned a limit on the data tableau
can receive with this api but can
tableau retrieve a pin from our studio
connect
so tableau
i believe the
show that what makes this problem
difficult to solve from tableau's
perspective is that tableau doesn't
um
allow you to just reach out to like a
regular plumber api
or
like python api it doesn't make requests
in that way
it sends
two types of requests
whenever it's it's reaching out from
tableau analytics extensions it's
expecting to hit an info endpoint that
gives
some data about
like what it's speaking to
and then the evaluate endpoint so
requesting
um a pin could potentially be set up
through
like that interface tableau has for
registering
data sources
but going through the same route to get
at pins i don't think would work unless
you have those pins available and
exposed through
the analytic extensions and i'm not sure
that the script parameter on tableau
would
allow you to set that up and make
that a functional data poll
um but again james would be a better
person to answer that question in more
detail
well thank you so much kelly for
jumping in here and answering some of
the remaining questions um i'll sync up
with lou from our team after this as
well and we can work on putting together
a blog post with the questions as well
to share
but just want to say thank you all for
joining today it was great to see so
many of you here
and another
great event will be
uh next week with tom mock who will be
going through
uh our studio hosted eval walkthrough if
anyone's interested
i did just share um
a flex dashboard i kind of made to share
upcoming meetups and events in case you
don't have access to meetup at work
but thank you all so much for joining if
you do ever have any other feedback or
things that you'd like to see
there's a google form in the chat too
we'd love to hear from you all
but thank you so much for joining and
have a great rest of the day
[Music]
you